the house will be in order
the prayer will be offered by our
chaplain chaplain kibben
would you pray with me
sovereign god these times are in your
hands
incline your ear to us and hear our
prayers for our congress
for our nation
for its people
as compatriots we are too often
separated by politics and perspectives
individual certainties and intractable
opinions
on this anniversary of national discord
and despair
send your healing spirit among us and
tend to the dispiritedness and
disagreement here within and around the
people's house
this day into your hands we commend our
spirits of fear
anger
and uncertainty
and ask that you would revive in us our
shared commitment to this country's
highest ideals
its strength in its diversity
its power and its defense of the common
good
on these virtues was our country founded
and for them countless heroes have
sacrificed
remind us
inspire us
the aggrieved
the skeptical
the disenfranchised
all of us to hold true
and remain worthy of this noble heritage
we offer the words of abraham lincoln
that once again we would emerge from our
national turmoil with malice toward none
and charity for all
with firmness in the right as you give
us to see the right
to finish the work we are in
to bind up the nation's wounds
to do all which may achieve and cherish
a just and lasting peace among ourselves
merciful god restore to us this sacred
obligation of unity and moral purpose
inspire us to live lives which serve as
a witness to your restoration and
reconciliation
we pray your peace over your people in
your sovereign name we pray
amen
section 11a of resolution
188 the journal of the last day's
proceedings is approved the pledge of
allegiance we
will be led by the gentleman from
massachusetts mr mcgovern
pursuant to section 4a of house
resolution 829 no organization or
legislative business will be conducted
on this day the chair will address the
germ the chamber
today one year ago the capital and those
who work within it were targeted in a
violent insurrection that sought to
undermine democracy
as we acknowledge the horror of that day
we honor the heroism of so many
particularly u.s capitol police
institutional staff floor leadership
committee and member staff
we had a session this morning
where we could say thank you to many of
them unfortunately covet did not enable
us to have the full house we will have
another time when the attending
physician allows but as we acknowledge
the horror of that day in the face of
extreme danger they all risked
their safety for our democracy by
protecting the capital complex members
staff press etc uh press within
safeguarding the ballots in those
mahogany boxes
about
to validate the election and ensuring
that congress could accomplish our
purpose in our honor honor our duty to
the constitution and to our country
that day and in the days after
they were the defenders of our democracy
and their courage and patriotism
remain an inspiration
because of them
congress was able
to defeat the insurrection to return to
the capitol that same night to ensure
that the peaceful transfer of power took
place because of them
and our members
the insurrection failed
one year later this sacred space where
members legislate children learn
visitors are welcomed was defiled and
damaged we know that as we reflect on
that darkest day we remember that the
insurrection sought not only to attack
the building but to undermine democracy
itself
when the violent assault was made on the
capitol its purpose was to thwart
congress's constitutional duty to
validate the electoral count and to
ensure the peaceful transfer of power
but the assault did not deter us from
our duty i say again in this capital a
symbol of democracy to the world that
evening the congress because of the
courage of all the view
rose to honor oath and protect our
democracy
we did so honoring the words of
president lincoln during the civil war
fellow citizens he said we cannot escape
history we will be remembered in spite
of ourselves
no personal ins significance or
insignificance
can spare us one or another
we hold the power
therefore we bear the responsibility
lincoln said
today we accept responsibility as
daunting and demanding as any that
previous generations of leadership have
faced
since the january 6th inspiration there
have been continued assaults on our
democracy undermining the sanctity of
the vote and integrity of our elections
which are the basis of our democracy
let us be true to the vision of our
founders who brilliantly established our
democracy and made it a model for the
world
let us honor the sacrifice of our men
and women in uniform who protect that
freedom with their lives
and let us remember the words of another
president our patriarch
george white president george washington
when he delivered the constitution
to the congress
he said this
he said this constitution represents the
creation of a government which would
allow for the continuation of rigorous
debate
but relies upon the common sense and
good faith of the american people to
find the better angels of our nature
as we proceed let us find our common
ground reach our nation's heights with
liberty and justice for all remembering
the words of our great patriarch and in
the spirit that our
chaplain referenced of president lincoln
with malice toward none with charity
toward all
let us acknowledge today
as i conclude i want to acknowledge
our fallen heroes of that day
u.s capitol police officer brian
sicknick
u.s capitol police officer howard living
good
metropolitan officer jeffrey smith
u.s capitol police officer billy evans
of a later assault
now i ask all members to rise for a
moment of silence in their memory
she
thank you
pursuant to section 11b of past
resolution 188 the house stands
adjourned until 6 30 p.m on monday
january 10th
2022
you